رئيس الاوكرانيس في استعاده قوات بلاده
مدينه خيرسون بالتاريخيه داعيا الجنود
الروس في مناطق الجنوب اوكرانيا الى
الاستسلام وفيما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
اكتشاف دبابات ومعدات اخرى خلفتها القوات
الروسيه اعلن الروس اكتمال عمليات نقل
قوته من الضفه اليمنى لنهر دروبو منتخبين
مدينه غرينتشك عاصمه مؤقته للاقليم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسرات اي دلالات لظروف
الميدانيه والسياسيه التي دخلت ضمنها
القوه الاوكرانيه مدينه خيرسون وانسحاب
القوات الروسيه منها
ما مدى مصداقيه التوقعات الامريكيه
بتداعيه اوسع لاستعاده القوات الاوكرانيه
خيرسون وما هي خطط موسكو حيل ذلك
الراهنه على الجهود الرميه لالهاء الحرب
السلميا في ضوء المواقف الصادره من طرفيها
وداعممها
[موسيقى]
الان وقد اضحك مدينه خرسون بيد القوات
الاوكرانيه يكون الواقع الميداني وجنوبيه
اوكرانيا قد تحرك في اتجاه مشهد مختلف
بدرجه معتبره متى هو الفاصل الطبيعي بين
قوات البلدين المتحاربين واضعا قرار روسيا
تم المقاط الاربعه على المحك وكذلك خطط
اوكرانيا لاستعادتها بالكامل بين هذا وذاك
حديث عن جمود ميداني قادم بحكم الامر
الواقع قد يفسح المجال لحراك سياسي ما
ينتهي او ربما يبدا بالتفاوض وسط
التساؤلات ان كان ذلك سيكون المقصد واشنطن
من حديثها عن تداعيات او ساعه لاستعاده
خلصن من الروس ايا كان الحال فانزل امسكي
الحدث يمر دون ان يعبر عن زهوه بالتاكيد
على ان الوحدات الخاصه في الجيش الاوكراني
موجوده حاليا وسط المدينه
وكريستيان
لاوكرانيا
نحن نعيد خلصن قواتنا اصبحت داخل المدينه
المواطنون انتظروا جنودنا انا سعيد جدا
على الرغم من التهديدات الروسيه الناس
يخرجون للشوارع ويزيلون كل اثار العدوان
الروسي ستعيد اوكرانيا كل ما هو كلها
قواتنا سيطرت على كل المواقع وسوف تبدا
اجراءات اعاده الاستقرار الى اخرسي وفي
مقدمتها ازاله الالغام لقد تركت القوات
الروسيه الكثيره منها قوات الدفاع ستؤهل
كل شيء وستعود المشافي الى عملها سنعيد
الحياه من جديد
العاصمه تركيا في شهدت احتفالات اثر اعلان
دخول قواتها المسلحه مدينه خرسون بعد
انسحاب القوات الروسيه من الضفه الغربيه
من نهر النيبرو وردد المحتفرون هتافات
التاييد لوحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه ودعم
القوات المسلحه التي قالوا انها تحقق
انتصارات متتاليه في جبهات القتال
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليه الجنوب
الاوكرانيه نتاليا هونيو قالت ان قوات
بلادها اكتشفت دبابات ومدافع ومعدات
الروسيه اخرى في الاراضي المحرره في
الجنوب بعد فشل الروس في عبور نهر النيبرو
بها اثناء الانسحاب واضافته هناك متروكه
بشكل فوضوي وان الجيش الاوكراني يجمع ما
يناسبه منها لاستخدامه في الهجوم المضاد
كما اكدت همن يوكن روسا زرعوا مساحات
كبيره من الاراضي التي غدروها بالالغام
لذلك فان العوده الى الاراضي المحرره لا
تزال محفوفه بالمخاطر
اما عن الجانب الروسي فقد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اكتمال عمليات نقل قواتها
من الضفه اليمنى لنهر النيبرو في مقاطعه
خرسون الى الضفه اليسرى من النهر واوضحت
الوزاره انه تم سحب اكثر من 30 الف جنديا
وخمسه الاف وحده من الاسلحه والمعدات
بدوره قال لكريملن ان الموقف من وضع خرسون
كجزء من روسيا لم يتغير
[موسيقى]
الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من موسكو الدكتور
الثاني
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه وفي واشنطن
الدكتور دونالد جونسون الدبلوماسي
الامريكي السابق في موسكو ومن عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي
مرحبا بكم جميعا دكتور
الاوكراني الى مدينه خرسون ياتي بعد اعلان
التعبئه في روسيا وتغيير في القياده
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا هل يحرج هذا
الكرملين الرئيس الروسي وموسكو
راشينج
ولكن الاهانه
في الضفه اليمنى لنهر ديني برو كان امرا
صعبا واقفا عن خرسان بالنظر الى المشاكل
اللوجستيه كان تعبان انا منذ ثلاثه اشهر
كان واضحا انه من الجانب العسكري كان هناك
حاجه ماسه للعوده الى الضفه اليسرى من
النهر من اجل ان يكون هناك طبيعي حيث من
الممكن ان ننظيمه خطى الدفاع عنهم
منذ السابع عشر كان واضح ان هذا الجزء من
رانيا الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر دنيبر وهو
اقرب اكثر الى روسيا
مقارنه بالاراضي الى الضفه اليمنى ولكنني
اعتقد اننا نتجهون نحو توازن عسكري انفعها
القول
ونوع من المفاوضات السلميه التي يمكن ان
تبدا مباشره بعد الوصول الى هذا النوع من
التوازن اسيا والعسكري ايضا
الجنرال مليليه قال
بعد همم
اوكرانيا ان تسيطر على شبه جزيره
القرمجه
اذا بعد هذا التوازن العسكري الذي ارسيناه
اعتقد انه سيكون منطقيا ان نحقق نوع من
الهدنه او وقفه اطلاق النار
مع تسريبات الاسبوع الماضي اشارت الى ان
اداره الرئيس بيضا طالبت اوكرانيا بان
تكون اكثر مرونه في التفاوض مع الرئيس
الروسي
انا
احراج كبير للجيش الروسي هذا الوحدات التي
انسحبت
الجوده
جيد ولكن ربما الان تعززات
فعل الناس في شوارع خيرصون يحملون الاعلام
الاوكرانيه
ايضا يغنون النشيد الوطني الاوكراني هذا
يوضح انهم يريدون ان يكون جزءا من
اوكرانيا هذا احراج للجيش الروسي
وعملياتها بالنسبه الى موضوع المفاوضات من
المهم هنا ان نتحدث عن الجنرال ميني الذي
تحدث تعبيرا عن راي الشخصي لا مؤشر الى ان
الاداره الامريكيه تضغط على اوكرانيا
للتفاوض هذا قرار اوكراني مستقل الى ان
حلفاءنا الغربيين يضغطون على اوكرانيا
كما قال زميلي الروسي احيانا او ربما سنصل
الى توازنات من نوع ما قد نصل الى ذلك لست
اكيدا لكن اعتقد ان اوكرانيا سوف تدخل في
عمليات عدائي عسكريه في الاسابيع والاشهر
المقبله مع ان الطقس يزداد رداء اذان
كبير ضربه كبيره للجيش الروسي
هذا ضربه سياسيه لبوتين وللكريم لين
واعتقد ان صداها سوف يكون في ميدان
المعركه وايضا في الداخل الروسي
هذا التقدم الاوكراني في مدينه خرسونجا
النتيجه انسحاب روسي اصلا من هذه المنطقه
اليس نتيجه
تماس مباشر او معركه مباشره الى ماذا يؤثر
هذا
يعني هو جاء نتيجه قراءه من قبل القاده
ااه الميدانيين والرؤوس وبالتالي قائد
العمليات وكان الواضحا جدا في الاجازه
الذي قدمه الى وزير الدفاع عندما قال نتخذ
قرارابا او قرا يعني ليس بالسهوله ان يتم
اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار لكن لماذا تخذ لان
الظروف والواقع الميداني كان يلزمه ان
يتخذ هذا القرار القرار كما ي- بمعنى اخر
كما يتجر عن السم لماذا لان الواقع
العملياتي كان يميل لصالح القوات
الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه اجادت لعبه
تدمير خطوط الامداد ومنع اي تعزيزات تصل
وبدات قدره القوات الروسيه تتاكل طبيعه
الارض كانت تساعد القوات الخطه التي
اعتقد انها كانت في في طور بدايه التنفيذ
وقراناها وق ها غيرنا وكنا نقول تتالف من
ثلاثه ابعاد هجمات جبهويه مع تنفيذ
اختراقات مع احاطه
لمحاصره الجيش وبالتالي استسلامه او
تدميره في ظل عدم وجود امدادات كان قرارا
صعبا لكن يلاحظ
وتم الحديث حول اليه ميكانيكيه الانسحاب
فاختار القائد الروسي الانسحاب السريع
ومما يثبت ذلك انه استطاع ان ينقل اكثر من
30,000 مع 5,000 من المعدات لكن الذي يثبت
انه كان ليس بالانسحاب المتناسق
رغم انه ليس تحت الضغط اؤكد رغم انه ليس
تحت الضغط انما جاء انسحابا سريعا لاخلاء
كل ما يمكن اخلاقه فتم التخلي عن العديد
من الاليه لماذا لان القراءه كانت تشير اي
تاخير يسير لصالح يشيل الاوكراني وسيتم
ايقاع خسائر اضافيه ف فضل ان يخرج بما
لديه ولا يخسر ما بين يديه همم دكتور سان
ستيف طبعا خيرسون ضمن المقاطعات الاربعه
التي اعلن الرئيس الروسي ضمها الى روسيا
الان بعد هذا الانسحاب واعاده الجيش
الاوكراني السيطره على هذه المنطقه المهمه
ما مصير هذه القرارات
الرسميه
هذه المناطق الى روسيا
لا اكثر ولا اقل ولن يغير الكثير
لا يتم استخدام
المجندين الروس في هولا لم يكن هناك اي
تصعيد نووي وبالتالي دوم هذا
اراد الى روسيا لم يغير الكثير في العمليه
العسكريه كان مجرد خطوه رمزيه
للبعث برساله الى داخل الروسيه في المسار
الصحيح
استراتيجيا غير مسار العمليه لاحقا حين
نجري المفاوضات هذه الحدود يمكن اعاده
ترسيمها ويمكن للكرام لان يوافق على حدود
جديده لم لا تقريبا
وبالتالي سيكون هناك تنازلات يعاد ترسيم
الحدود ويقع اتفاق سلام اعتقد ان رسلتزل
بحاجه الى بعض الوقت من اجل ان تستخدمه
قدرات على حجم الجنود او الجيوش وبالتالي
اوكرانيا قد يكون عليها ان تمضي اشهر لكي
تغير استراتيجيه او لكي تواجهها
استراتيجيه الحج الجديده روسيا بالنسبه
الى روسيا روسيا بحاجه الى بطاقه اشهر من
اجل ان تستخدمه من من تحتاج اليه متحضرهم
للقتال اعتقد انه في بدايه السنه المقبله
او حتى في شهر ديسمبر من هذا العام سيكون
من الاصعب على الكره الاخرىنيه
التقدم طبعا
يمكننا ان نلتقي في شهر يناير من العمل
المقبل لنرى اذا حققت فعلا المزيد من
النجاح ولكن مع كل اسبوع وشهر سيصير الامر
اصعب على اوكرانيا حتى تتقدم طبعا كان
هناك موقف امريكي من هذا من هذا التقدم
الاوكراني مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسال قال ان الاوكرانيين حققوا انتصارا
كبيرا واضاف سواليفنا ان الولايات المتحده
تبذل كل ما في وسعها لتقديم المساعده
الامنيه لاوكرانيا لتكون في افضل وضع ممكن
في ساحه المعركه وعلى طاوله المفاوضات
وقال سلفا ان روسيا تضاعف جهودها لضم
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا ليس علامه على
الجديه في التفاوض حسب تعبيره واكد سلفا
ان الامر متروك لاوكرانيا لتقرر متى وكيف
تريد التفاوض مع روسيا مضيفا ان بلاده لن
تضغط على الاوكرانيين ولن تملي عليهم ما
يجب ان يفعلها همم دكتور همم جونسون طبعا
كيف يمكن ان تنظر امام هذا الواقع
والتراجع الروسي كيف يمكن ان تنظر دول
حليفه لموسكو في هذه المرحله وتدخل معها
في حلف مثل الصين لهذا التراجع والاحراج
كما وصفته انت في خرسانه
مع الصين
تراقبوا عن كذب هذا الوضع بالنظر الى
مشاكلها الخاصه مع تايوان
على غرار الكثيرين بالنظر الى ضعف اداء
الجيش الروسي اود ان ننوها بنقطه انا
اوافق زميلي الروسيه ان ايقاع التقدم
الاوكراني
الى العراق الجغرافيه وجود النهر وعوامل
اخرى مثل ان دوم بس
مناطق مدنيه
هناك عدد من المناطق التي يمكن لاوكرانيا
ان تدخلها الان والتي لن تجمد لن توقف
تقدمها مذكركم بان اودسه ليست بعيده عن
خيرسون عفوا انا اقول اقصد القرم وليس انا
لا اقول انهم سوف يستعدون القرن قريبا
لكنهم سيضغطون على
خطوط التواصل
الروسيه التي تمت عرق خالتها وبالتالي يجب
ان نرى القياده الاوكرانيه المتميزه التي
اثبت التميزها يهمنا ان نرى كيف ستتحرك
بعد ذلك
سيطره الجيش الاوكراني على اخر صن على
مشروع الرئيس الروسي في الجنوب على البحر
الاسود
ربما لاحقا ما تداعيات المتوقعه لهذا
التغير او التغيير في الواقع على الارض
يعني خلال الفتره المحدوده جدا القادمه لا
يكون هناك اي ايقاعات جديده لماذا لان
القوات التي تم انسحابها الجيش الروسي
الذي تم انسحابه الان هو يعمل على بناء خط
الدفاعي جديد يستند الى نهر دنبرو وهذا
سياخذ منه بعض الوقت الجيش الاكراني
وبدرجه اقل وبدرجه اقل سيكون مشغولا بعض
وحداته في اعاده تهيئه وتامين المنطقه
سواء من جيوب مقاومه من بقايا ااا عسكريين
او عملاء او عمليات همم الالغام وما شابه
ذلك
فحريه الحركه للقوات الاوكرانيه افضل
نسبيا من حريه استغلال القوات الروسيه في
الفتره القادمه كيف يمكن استخدام هذه
القوات هي التي تجيب على سؤالك مباشره
هذه القوات يقدر عددها نظريا بذاءا على
المقاييس الحرب من الحرب العالميه الثانيه
والكوري وغير ذلك انها يجب ان تتراوح ما
بين 90 الى 120,000 مقاتل هذه القوات اين
ستتجه ستتجه هناك اولويه الاولويه الاولى
قد تكون باتجاهي زباروجيا لماذا لان
الزبرجيا لم يجري بها معاركمه
وحجم القوات فيها اقل مما هو في دون باس
سواء دونيسك او لوغاز او ما تبقى من
خارجيه اثنين هي اقرب باتجاه حركه القوات
ثلاث هي ستدخل نهر النيبرو ليس من مناطق
عمليات ولكن من مناطق خاضعه للصيطره
الاوكرانيه ففي هذه الحاله لا يعتبر
مانعنع اذن الان هل تختار ان تتجه الى
زبرجه
اولويه رقم واحد من وجهه نظري ابوظيه رقم
اثنين ان تتجه الى همم الى الدونيسسك
لماذا لان جبهه الدنست تشكل خطوره عكسيه
على اوكرانيا في منطقه باخمد هل تحاول ان
ترجع واول خيار الثالث اللي هو بقيه اقليم
الدوم بس النتائج ماذا ستحقق هي التي
ستجيب على السؤال
الرئيسه وعلى ضوء المواقف الصادره همم من
الطرفين دكتور ستان ستلاف السؤال الاخير
ربما ملان كاسات المتوقعه للتطورات
الميدانيه على محاولات ايجاد حل سلمي
للحرف في اوكرانيا
القوات الاوكرانيات سوف تحاول ان تحقق
النجاح في منطقه زبروشه هذا واضح ربما
سيكون هناك اعتداء على باردونس
لن يحصل
في الغرب وفي اوكرانيا الذين يطالبون
باعاده ترسيم الحدود بحسب حدود العام 91
حكي عن ان اوكرانيا سوف تسيطر على القرم
في
2023 اعتقدوا ان هذا ضرب من الخيال لانه
من السهل الدفاع هرم طبعا
خطوط التواصل ولكن السيطره على القرم
سيكون عمليه صعبه على الارجان يحصل
شكرا لكم الدكتور السنه سلاف مطرقهوفيتش
في موسكو الدكتور دونالد جونسون في واشنطن
والواء فايز الدويري في عمان
الى هنا تنتهي ذا الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله
[موسيقى]